this episode of the show is brought to
you by Squarespace the tool to use to
make a website for your business for
your brand more about them in a bit
here's the greatest president we never
had it's the sort of opening line you
can imagine using for a number of
figures for those in American history
who narrowly lost elections or simply
never gained their party's nomination a
lament for those who should have been in
the white house but never quite got
there but that's not the sort of person
today's video is about rather we're
using the greatest president we never
had to describe someone who literally
did become President James A Garfield
was elected in 1880 in one of the
tightest campaigns ever fought on
entering the White House the following
spring he became the 20th U.S president
yet America never got to see what it'd
be like in office just 100 days into his
turn Garfield was shot while waiting for
a train although he held on for a couple
of months an infection in the wound
eventually spelled his doom and that's a
great shame because the potential was
there for Garfield to become a
spectacular president a deeply moral man
who'd grown up in poverty Garfield was a
champion of civil rights and determined
to reform a corrupt system that he died
before doing so maybe one of America's
greatest forgotten tragedies
[Music]
one of the weirdest aspects of modern
politics is watching multi-millionaires
try to approve their working class
credentials to claim a background of
adversity even while sitting on a stock
portfolio most of us could only ever
dream of James A Garfield would have
laughed at people like that unlike
today's poses the 20th President really
did grow up in biting poverty born on
the Ohio Frontier on November 19 1831
Garfield has the distinction of being
the last president born in a log cabin
but while the reality of life in early
America meant that you could be born in
a little cabin while still making it big
the only thing big about Garfield's
early life was the Staggering adversity
his father a stout farmer and amateur
wrestler died when the boy was only one
leaving Garfield's mother pannulas to
give you just some idea of how Paul the
family was they couldn't afford shoes
for the boy until he was four as a
result of this upbringing the 20th
President would spend his life with what
seems like a massive case of imposter
syndrome a feeling that he somehow
didn't deserve to be among the Gilded
Elite Washington which is all sorts of
strange when you think about it as
Garfield's life was basically the
American dream made real poor he may
have been but the boy was also
exceptionally bright far more capable
and intelligent than anyone else in
their corner of the world and people
recognize this his mother scrimped and
saved to try and find money to send him
to school his older brother went out to
work at 11 just to help raise the 17
they needed for Garfield's education not
that the boy initially wanted to study
having grown into a big Burly land with
powerful arms just like his old dad the
teenage boy was convinced his future lay
in a life of adventure as a sailor not
in being a boring old Bookworm age 16 he
ran away hightailing it to the Erie
Canal to work on the boats and
experience Adventure what he got instead
it was a big great dollop of humility
unable to swim Garfield was almost
comically unsuited to Canal work by his
own admission he fell in the water and
had to be rescued 14 times in six weeks
on top of that he contracted malaria and
eventually wound up being sent home to
recover and with that lesson learned the
boy she officially returned to education
it would be the smartest movie ever made
although he had the build of Popeye's
nemesis Pluto Garfield's mind was like a
storehouse for knowledge he could absorb
books like a nerdy sponge and had soon
mastered mathematics and ancient
languages as well as gaining a
respectable grounding in literature in
history of course he's led to work to
supplement his mother's meager savings
first as a carpenter then as a janitor
the boy who act himself or ragged to get
through school to get the education that
could change his life this is the
American dream part of the tale the part
where Garfield works his ass off and
through sheer grit and intelligence
alone goes in two years from working as
the school's janitor to being one of its
professors perhaps most impressively he
did all of this while keeping an
optimistic Outlook as a Young Man
Garfield was one of those people you're
always happy to see the kind of guy
who'll give you a bear hug buy you a
drink tell you a dirty joke and then
leave you crying with laughter he hunted
he drank he chased the ladies at one
point keeping three women on the Go at
once yeah there was also a deeper side
to him one that brought students
flocking to his lectures that saw him
trained to become a Christian minister
that's all that extroverted young man at
last turned to the career that would
make his name
politics this was the mid-1850s when
slavery was the issue of the day and a
radical new party had just formed to
oppose its expansion known as the
Republican party it would draw in James
Garfield giving him a way to express his
anti-slavery beliefs giving him support
when he ran for the Ohio legislature
becoming the state's youngest lawmaker
but it was also the Republican party
that would soon draw Garfield into the
biggest test of his life War
you can see the effect the febrile
atmosphere of the late 1850s was having
on Garfield from his correspondence that
how increasingly firm his anti-slavery
beliefs became when he attended an
anti-slavery lecture as a younger man he
merely noted the [ __ ] had some funny
remarks and witty too by 1860 though he
felt comfortable writing I'm inclined to
believe that the sin of slavery is one
of which it may be said that without the
shedding of blood there is no remission
which is a clunky 19th century way of
saying that the future president was
more than happy to settle the issue in
battle we know this because Owen war
broke out in April of 1861 Garfield was
among those cheering loudest not because
he supported the Confederacy but because
the north finally had an excuse to head
south and smash up the slave system that
year 1861 Garfield began recruiting for
the regiment that it soon lead the 42nd
Ohio volunteers it was an easy task the
future president was still lecturing at
this point and swaths of his students
signed up to serve under him driven as
much by person loyalty as by their
desire to punish Dixie although he was a
natural fighter Garfield was also keenly
aware that the fate of these men rested
on him during training it blow through
entire nights determinedly reading up on
military tactics in this way he was not
dissimilar to another President we
recently covered Benjamin Harrison who
was also a bookish and brave Soldier and
also born in Ohio but while Harrison
would approach War assembly and with a
feeling of heavy duty James Garfield
approached it like a bat out of hell his
first significant action was at the
Battle of Middle Creek in January 1862.
there he managed to direct his forces in
such a way that the much larger
Confederate grouping thought they were
being attacked by multiple regiments and
went into Retreat a stunning Victory
pulled off with limited resources in
fact it was so stunning that it left
Garfield in charge of the whole of
Eastern Kentucky by March it chased the
Confederates out of the rest of the
state so impressive was this win that he
was made Brigadier General that summer
while Garfield was on leave with
dysentery his friends sought to
capitalize on this by putting his name
forward for election to the House of
Representatives he won without doing any
campaigning but since he wasn't required
to report to Washington for a whole year
Garfield went straight back to the South
for another round of War this time
though he'd witnessed an embarrassing
Union defeat the Battle of Chickamauga
in September 1863 was the sort of
hapless Omni disaster usually associated
with the modern UK conservative party
only instead of crashing the economy it
featured Union troops getting their
asses handed to them yet even amid this
utter show Garfield managed to cut out
smelling like roses one of the only
senior officers to return to the field
after the retreat began Garfield made a
daring ride under enemy fire to help
General Thomas's defense although this
didn't turn the tide of battle it was
enough to get him promote to Major
General the youngest man in the Union
Army to hold such a wreck it was also
the end of Garfield's military career
with the deadline to take his seat in
the house now looming the young man was
convinced to permanently leave the
battlefield and honestly it may have
saved his soul in Washington Garfield
would admit to friends that war had
shaken him badly as one later wrote
something went out of him that never
came back the sense of the sacredness of
life and the impossibility of destroying
it yet this glimpse of brutality would
ignite a new Fire Inside the Man a
desire not just to see the union win the
war but to win the peace as well now
interrupt this video to tell you about
one of our long time sponsors it is of
course Squarespace look you've heard me
talk about Squarespace before and if
you're making a website anywhere else in
2022 well in that case you're making a
mistake because there is no better no
easier place to make a website than
Squarespace they make it super easy all
you got to do you go over to their site
and I'd recommend you use a template
templates are just easier for me I've
got no design skills I have no coding
skills I went over to Squarespace they
showed me some templates that I might
like I chose one of them
I add some pictures I customize some
text I add another page if I want to
only want to add another page you're
like I need a contact form they're like
well we have a template for that and you
just slot it in in there and it's just
it's that easy it is slotting it in
there is just as easy as it is plus
there's loads of other features you can
use for example like I say you want to
put a contact form on there it's really
easy and then you don't have to like
have your email address out there on the
internet which is never a good thing
you'll get all sorts of spam put a
contact form on there people can reach
out to you very easily plus all the
usual stuff analytics blogs Etc there
isn't a better place to build a website
so go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com biographics you got
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain and let's get back to
today's video shall we
[Music]
to watch James A Garfield's career from
war to the end of reconstruction is to
watch a radical star slowly lose his
fire and dim into a chilly pragmatist
when he first entered the house Garfield
was perhaps the most radical member
arguing for the seizure of Southern
Property for the execution of
Confederates for the South to be beaten
to its knees so long as slavery was
around he wouldn't rest he wouldn't cool
off as he wrote in his diary slavery be
damned yet for all the fire he directed
towards the South's peculiar institution
Garfield was no John Brown in fact his
radicalism seems to have masked a deeply
conflicting set of racial views as 1865
saw the Confederacy limped towards
defeat the future president began openly
supporting black suffrage at the same
time though he was privately writing to
a friend it goes against the grade of my
feelings to favor negro suffrage for I
never could fall in love with the
creatures from our vantage point this
seems little screwy but then those were
the times times in which virtually all
white people even those who were
anti-slavery had been brought up to
consider Black Folk inferior and while
Garfield may have privately harbored
unpc views his actions almost always
supported equality that meant voting for
the Civil Rights Act of 1866 for the
Reconstruction amendments for the Ku
Klux Klan act that effectively outlawed
the organization it meant likewise
voting for Andrew Jackson's 1868
impeachment yet it would be wrong to
claim his voting record was predictable
the longer reconstruction went on the
more Garfield's radical side started to
cool whereas 1863 Garfield had called
for the Smashing of the South the
Garfield of reconstruction was more
cautious advocating reconciliation over
confrontation for some colleagues this
was an infuriating sign that there was
nothing to him but his opinions would
just blow in the wind like a field of
ripe corn to which Garfield's Defenders
could reply with his clear commitment to
America's newly enfranchised black
citizens to the speeches he may made
passionately condemning the waves of
lynching that had broken out sadly
though it's here that we come to another
great contradiction in the story of
James A Garfield in the long run his
actions may have only made the problems
facing black Southerners that much worse
the trigger point was the 1876 election
between Republican Rutherford B Hayes
and Democrat Samuel Tilden now because
we perhaps foolishly set about conveying
the president's emotionally reverse
order you'll have to wait until our Haze
video to get the real Lowdown on what
happened but the simple version is that
the results were unbelievably close
while the Democrats won the popular vote
by three points the Electoral College
was gridlocked with 185 electoral votes
needed to win Tilden had 184 while Hayes
had 165. that left 20 electoral votes
still in play just enough to decide the
competition in the Deep South three
states were each reporting two sets of
electors one for Hayes and one for
Tilden which meant Congress now need to
figure out who was going to be president
in the Electoral commission that
followed Garfield served as one of the
Republicans investigating the outcome we
say investigating in air quotes here
because oh and the time came all the
Republicans on the committee voted on
party lines to award Hayes the 20
disputed electors this took him to 185
the exact number needed to claim victory
and become president it again opened the
door to a bargain with the devil in the
tense atmosphere following Hayes Victory
Republicans cut a back room deal with
Tilden and the Democrats if Democrats
went along with President Hayes the
north would pull all of its troops out
of the South a reconstruction it would
be over and all of the South black
citizens would be left at the mercy of
their former overlords it was the
beginning of a near Century of
Oppression of civil rights denied and
deeply racial violence in short it was
everything Garfield had made all those
fine speeches arguing against And yet
when push came to shove it had been his
actions that had indirectly helped usher
in Jim Crow
over the 17 years he sat in the house
Garfield witnessed all sorts of
political arguments come and go over
silver-backed money over the legality of
labor unions but there was one constant
from start to finish corruption this was
the Great era of patronage when a key
point of becoming a representative was
not to just shove your own snout into
the trough but also those of everyone
whoever did you a political favor the
federal government had no concept of
meritocracy no exams that needed to be
taken to fulfill non-political posts
Beyond one we might call Advanced
kissing the result was a system so
entrenched so corrupt that pretty much
everyone got ensnared in it it would
take super human character to resist and
James A Garfield was no Superman like a
certain fat orange cat left alone with
John's dinner Garfield couldn't help but
snaffle a slice of that delicious
lasagna only in reality John was the
taxpayer and his lasagna was the federal
budget over the years the future
president was caught taking money to
help a construction company avoid
Federal oversight handing out a corrupt
Paving contract and voting to give
himself a retroactive raise not that it
hurt his career prospects in this great
swampy era corruption was less of a
hindrance than getting on the wrong side
of powerful people and Garfield was a
natural at making people at the top like
him you can see this from the way he
balanced between the two major
Republican factions of his era the
starwoods who organized under Ulysses S
Grant and the slightly more reformist
half-breeds under James G Blaine able to
tiptoe between both camps by 1880
Garfield was one of the few people the
entire party could do business with
which may explain the upset that
happened at the party convention that
year as the GOP gathered to nominate its
presidential candidate a deadlock emerge
between stalwarts trying to re-nominate
former President Grant and half breeds
pumping for James G Blaine now this
wasn't meant to be a problem going in
there had already been a compromise
candidate lined up in the form of
Treasury secretary John Sherman yet it
wouldn't be Sherman who wound up getting
the nomination on the 34th ballot 16
votes were suddenly put forward for
Garfield one ballot later the number had
jumped at 50. sensing a chance to screw
over the starwoods the half-breeds leapt
on Garfield's bandwagon John Sherman's
supporters followed them by the end a
ballot 36 the results were clear Ulysses
S Grant's come back and failed James A
Garfield would be the Republican nominee
to call this a setback for the starwoods
would be a bit of an understatement they
couldn't have been more shocked if
Garfield had personally even Grant an
atomic wedgie sadly for the new nominee
though even with this setback the
starwoods were still powerful powerful
enough to get their own man on the
ticket Chester A Arthur a man who'd come
up under the tutelage of corruption
Superstar an all-round Machiavellian
Mischief maker Senator Roscoe Conklin
Arthur was everything the half breeds
hated it was also essential to Garfield
having a cat in Hell's chance of winning
in November the Star Wars weren't stupid
the man they had forced onto the VP
ticket was from Conklin's power base of
New York and with 35 electoral votes up
for grab New York was a state Garfield
could not afford to lose hence the
meeting the new nominee took there on
August 5th a meeting OA Garfield
promised the Star Wars he wouldn't
forget them oh and it came to handing
out posts although conkling himself
wasn't there the meeting had his
fingerprints all over it which meant he
was now more than happy to use New
York's political machine to help
Garfield win on November 2nd 1880
Garfield went up against Democrat
winfreed s Hancock in a nail by driven
election Garfield netted the narrowest
popular boat to win on record carrying
the day by less than .1 but with New
York's 35 electoral votes in the bag the
Electoral College was his having helped
the now president-elect over the line
the stalwarts and conkling could breathe
easy certain the new guy would unrock
the corruption boat little did they know
that Garfield was already forming his
own plans plans that would understand
Conklin's career it would bring the
whole rotten edifice of the patronage
system tumbling down
foreign
when telling the story of Garfield's
presidency people normally just focus on
the juicy assassination part rather than
the Hundred Days leading up to it
certainly that's understandable after
all Garfield's unique among assassinated
presidents had no major event he oversaw
before dying no Civil War no Cuban
Missile Crisis no Spanish-American War
yet it's also only half the story
because to truly understand the long
impact of Garfield's short presidency
you have to first look at the big fight
that characterized his administration
the fight against corruption although
Garfield had come up within the
patronage system he seems to have been
deeply uneasy with it by 1880 it was
clear the lack of a dedicated civil
service class appointed on Merit was
holding America back that handing
powerful posts those who've done new
political favors was a shortcut to
dysfunctional government already the new
president was being hounded by people
who worked his campaign begging for jobs
like the Widow kept writing to him
demanding the ambassadorship to Vienna
in return for a pro Garfield's featured
bait much better the new president felt
to Simply sweep it all away the only
problem being that you'd have to get
past Senator Roscoe conkling as the
Beating Heart of corruption in U.S
politics Compton stood to lose money and
Authority if Garfield's reforms went
through moreover he felt that it helped
steer New York into Garfield's Camp
during the election rather than reform
the patronage system the President
should be using it to appoint whoever
the hell Conklin wanted it was this
power struggle that took up most of
Garfield's time in office a period in
which the president tried to push
through reforms while Conklin And the
stalwarts tried to block them luckily
Garfield lived just long enough to see
himself Victorious The Showdown came and
the president went over Conklin's head
to appoint the new collector of the port
of authority Chester A Arthur's old job
incensed Conklin resigned from the
senate in protest it was a tricky move
in those days senators were selected by
their state rather than by popular vote
Conklin knew that New York would
re-elect him at which point he could
claim A Renewed mandate to fight
Garfield but the one time Machiavellian
had miscalculated New York could see the
wind was blowing in Garfield's Direction
after 14 years defining American
politics Roscoe Compton was now toast it
was the beginning of the ends of the
patronage system the first step towards
an overhaul that would forever end the
concept of Doling out jobs to talentless
supporters unfortunately this would make
one untalented Garfield support a very
unhappy back in the fall of 1880 Chester
Jay gitteau had gotten on stage in New
York before a small crowd and made a
barely literate speech in support of
James Garfield's candidacy although the
event was sanctioned by the Republican
Party turnout was abysmal barely anyone
saw the talk and those that did simply
clapped politely while side eyeing each
other and wondering is this guy for real
but that's not how guitto remembered it
in his eyes his speech had been the
thing that saved Garfield's campaign the
sprinkling of magic that had boosted him
to victory in New York and thus to
victory in the Electoral College being a
reasonable man gito felt this required a
reward for months now he'd been a
writing to Garfield asking for the
ambassadorship to Vienna if that wasn't
available then he was willing to take a
console trip to Paris he was still under
the delusion that his reward was coming
when news broke of Conklin's fall of
Garfield's plan to overhaul the
patronage system not long after ghetto
turned up at the White House in person
and was told firmly to give up on the
ambassadorship and just like that this
strange sick manned mind snapped if
Garfield was indeed threatening to
reform the system then gitto needed a
star what to take over in the Oval
Office as soon as possible and with
Chester A Arthur the VP that meant only
one thing Charles gitteau was going to
have to kill the president
it's a strange piece of dramatic irony
that around the same time guitar was
buying a gun and stalking the President
Garfield was writing assassination can
no more be guarded against than death by
lightning and it is not best to worry
about either which is a fine little
phrase but on the other hand dude you
are literally the president my guy
guarding against assassination comes
with the territory yeah but then no one
in 1880s America believed it necessary
although the first presidential
assassination had already taken place
when John Wilkes Booth had shot Abraham
Lincoln everyone agreed it was just one
of those awful things that happens in
war that the defeat of the Confederacy
had created special circumstances that
would never be repeated after all
presidents aren't like some European
Monarch they're elected and who would
possibly want to kill a leader elected
by their people so it was that on July
the 2nd 1881 President Garfield went to
catch a train surrounded up by
bodyguards but with only his unarmed
friend James G Blaine the company it was
a fine day and while he was traveling
for sad reasons to visit his or wife
Garfield field was in a fine mood that
morning had playfully wrestled with his
sons then done headstand for their
Amusement while singing Gilbert and
Sullivan songs he couldn't wait to get
out of Washington after his bruising
fight with Conklin he had finally got a
chance to relax except of course
Garfield will never leave the capital A
9 20 M Garfield was in the station
waiting for his chain when Charles
gateau stepped up behind him there were
two sharp cracks Garfield was heard to
shout why God what is this and then the
president was on the floor a bullet
wound in his back a pool of blood
collecting around him amazingly the
bullet had missed his vital organs that
Garfield received an identical wound
just a few years later he would have
survived but 1881 was still too early
too early for American doctors to have
learned an important lesson that
sticking unsterilized equipment into a
gaping wound is a really really good way
to kill someone from infection and
that's exactly what happened to Garfield
under the care of the improbably named
doctor doctor Willard Bliss and yes his
first name and title were both doctor
the president was subject to horrific
medical malpractice convinced the bullet
needed to be removed Bliss repeatedly
stuck his unsterilized fingers into the
wound Dill over the course of several
weeks The Bullet Hole became a foul
smelling swamp of pus the most calling
part Joseph Lister had already made his
world changing discoveries on the
importance of sterilization in Europe
doctors now routinely washed their hands
but not in America instead Bliss just
kept on letting more and more dirt and
bacteria into the festering hole at the
same time he cut the injured Garfield's
food intake to almost zero began purging
him pumping the president with quinine
and he vomited his stomach dry by these
methods the good doctor did what ghettos
badly aimed bullet had failed to do
James A Garfield died in awful pain on
September the 19th 1881 aged only 49. at
the end his body was riddled with
infection his Stout 201 pound frame had
been reduced to a mere 130 pounds it
said that his last words were a near
Ingo here and plea for pain relief at
the time of his death Garfield had been
president for only 200 days still the
second shortest tenure in history while
his assassination shook the country it
seemed he would leave no Legacy behind
that with chester a Arthur's Ascension
to the presidency Charles gateau's goals
would be fulfilled only that's not quite
how things worked out Out In The Bleak
aftermath of Garfield's death President
Arthur did something he'd have found
impossible only months before he pushed
through an ax in Garfield's name
reforming the Civil Service and killing
off the patronage system in doing so he
fulfilled the Dead Man's unlikely dream
of draining the Washington swamp
likewise Garfield's death also prompted
a much delayed medical Revolution faced
with high-profile evidence that Joseph
lister's theories were right American
doctors finally adopted the practice of
washing their hands and sterilizing
instruments doubtless they saved
thousands of lives every year not that
realizing poor Medical Care had killed
Garfield was enough to save Cato
although he tried to argue at trial that
the doctors were to blame ghetto was
found guilty of murder on the 30th of
June 1882 he danced up the steps of the
Gallows in Washington before being
hanged he was 40. today President
Garfield is barely remembered known only
for getting assassinated and sharing his
name with a cartoon cat if he's known at
all that is in many ways this is perhaps
the true tragedy of his tale here was a
self-made man who came from nothing who
was born into biting poverty and through
sheer talent and determination Rose to
become the most powerful person in the
country who then used that position to
try his damnedest to fight corruption
that had been entrenched for decades
with such a short tenure it's perhaps
inevitable that history would forget
James A Garfield but hopefully this
video has shown that it shouldn't be
this way that's if he can't be
remembered as a great president then we
can at least perhaps remember Garfield
as the greatest president who never
truly had
[Music]